[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présente le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
comme tous les lundis fr bonjour bonjour
d'être avec nous directeur adj de la
rédaction du Figaro et le politologue
Pascal Perin bonjour Pascal bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être là on va parler
avec vous de l'attaque terroriste qui a
eu lieu samedi soir à Paris et les
questions qu'elle pose sur le suivi
psychiatrique sur le suivi des fichers
et Alex alors que la saant a fait
allégance à l'état islamique elle pose
également la question du suivi d
radicalisés sortant de prison
effectivement les parlementaires ont
fait voter en 2021 une loi qui prévoyait
des mesures de sûreté pour ces personnes
condamnées pour terrorisme et qui sont
ensuite sorties de prison on en parle
dans quelques instants on en parle même
tout de suite puisque c'est également
l'info dans nos
région
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
dans le Var on retrouve guilem ricavi
bonjour guilem merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous directeur éditorial de Var
Matin et guilem c'est une double page à
lire ce matin dans votre journal sur
l'attaque de samedi à Paris double page
que vous proposez à vos lecteurs
oui double page dans laquelle on essaie
de comprendre le parcours la trajectoire
de cet assaillant on Essie de comprendre
comment Armand rajapour étudiant de 26
ans né à Neil sur scène de parents euh
de parents iraniens réfugiés iraniens a
pu passer à l'acte et commettre une
horreur on essaie de comprendre comment
cet étudiant qui s'était converti à
l'islam en 2015 qui avait déjà préparé
un attentat en 2016 qui avait passé 4
ans en prison et bien a pu commettre
cela on s'intéresse effectivement à ce
parcours un petit peu atypique et et on
revient sur quand même pas mal de fait
troublant notamment ce jeune assaillant
qui expliquait et qui a expliqué aux
enquêteurs qu'il avait été fasciné par
l'attentat de Nice qui expliquait qu'il
avait voulu lui-même partir combattre en
Syrie et donc à travers ce ce portrait
et bien on comprend ce qui a pu animer
ce terroriste qui a fait allégence à
l'état islamique et c'est à lire ce
matin dans vos pages Guillem double page
dans Var Matin et on regarde la Une de
votre journal Armand r La Folle
trajectoire c'est à la Une de Var Matin
merci beaucoup guilem d'avoir été avec
nous on va évidemment continuer à à
parler de ce sujet puisque l'auteur de
cette attaque a donc fait allégance à
l'état islamique c'est ce qu'a rappelé
guilem un passage à l'acte qui pose
plusieurs questions et qui a suscité des
réaction politique on voit ça avec Jér
rab déjà condamné dans une affaire de
terrorisme fich est malade psychiatrique
le profil de l'assaillant qui a tué une
personne et blessé deux autres samedi
soir à Paris alimente les réactions
politique à l'issue d'une réunion
sécuritaire dimanche soir à Matignon le
ministre de l'Intérieur a dévoilé une
première piste pour répondre à ce type
d'individu il a arrêté les soins à la
demande de certains médecins et donc ce
qu'il faut sans doute changer on l'a vu
autour de la première ministre c'est le
fait que le pouvoir public le préfet les
policiers puissent demander exiger des
injonctions de soins tous les politiques
invités dans les médias cherchent leur
réponse à ce type de drame côté France
insoumise il faut s'interroger sur le
suivi des individus comment ça se fait
qu'une personne qui a été fiché S et
manifestement échappé à la surveillance
quel est était l'état de ce suivi
psychiatrique j'espère que l'enquête qui
va s'ouvrir maintenant permettra de
faire les détails et de faire la lumière
surem DEES mais c'est à droite et à
l'extrême droite que les réactions étai
les plus vives
non seulement fich pour radicalisation
mais sort de prison donc je pense il
faut remettre sur la table le débat sur
la rétention de sûreté et qu'il est
temps d'arrêter les mots voilà moi j'en
ai un peu assez de venir commenter drame
après drame les mêmes faits même
tonalité à droite ericti demande de ne
plus être naïf face à des individus déjà
connus de la justice la droite doit
faire des propositions cette semaine et
rappelle qu'elle porte depuis plusieurs
années la question de la rétention de
sûreté qui doit permettre de maintenir
en prison des individus jugés encore
dangereux après qu'ils ont effectué leur
peine et on va voir évidemment les
questions toutes les questions que pose
cette nouvelle attaque d'abord la
question psychiatrique Gérald armanin
hier était l'invité du 20h et il a fait
une proposition il a souhaité que les
autorités puissent demander une
injonction de soins pour les personnes
radicalisées dont on sait qu'elles ont
des toubres psychiatriques afin d'éit un
passage à l' est-ce que c'est la bonne
réponse bah comp tenu du profil du de
l'assaillant j'ai envie de vous dire oui
bien sûr et on s'étonne même d'ailleurs
que ça soit pas fait parce que je pense
qu'il y a quand même une responsabilité
là de la part du corps médical enfin de
certains dans le corps médical qui ont
levé son son obligation de soin et c'est
c'est c'est toute la question je vais
vous dire une chose c'est c'est c'est
une réponse globale qu'il faut avoir et
c'est une réponse qui doit être une
réponse d'une grande fermeté j'ai
utiliser un slogan c'est pas un slogan
mais c'est une terroriste un jour
terroriste toujours finalement c'est ça
qui qui est un peu la le résumé je
dirais la la synthèse de tout ce qu'on
connaît depuis 2012 on s'aperçoit qu'à
chaque fois et bien l'individu qui est
passé à l'acte a des failles dans son
dossier judiciaire dans son dossier
médical et qu'à chaque fois et bien
c'est c'est quelqu'un qui est en
situation souvent de réitération on va
revenir sur cette question la
déradicalisation possible ou pas c'est
c'est aussi un débat Pascal sur la
question psychiatrique est-ce que ça
pose la question des failles du Pivi
psychiatrique en France et est-ce que la
réponse que tente d'apporter Gérald
haranin est la bonne alors c'est une
réponse parmi une panoplie de réponses
parce que on ne peut pas laisser cette
espèce cette sorte de djihadisme
ordinaire se diffuser dans la société
française et j'allais dire toutes les 3
semaines être là à commander à commenter
le meurtre de tel ou tel touriste ou de
tel ou tel citoyen en français ça va peu
à peu et ça d'ailleurs déjà maintenant
ça exaspère littéralement l'opinion et
les conséquences peuvent être des
conséquences graves d'autre part ça pose
le problème de de l'expertise
psychiatrique dont on sait qu'elle est
fragile et là semble-t-il on verra ce
qu'il en est euh il semble bien qu'une
partie des psychiatres consultés ont eu
une vision peut-être un peu irénique du
cas euh dernière remarque certains et en
particulier à la France insoumise
Monsieur Manuel bonpard Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ont mis en avant j'allais dire
le critère psychiatrique en disant voilà
ça pose la question de l'équipement
psychiatrique en France je trouve ça
même un peu fort de café parce que on le
voit bien cet individu depuis 9 ans
connaît des problèmes psychiatriques
mais est un véritable terroriste ça il
n'en est pas à son à son premier acte
terroriste il a une véritable carrière
terroriste et bien sûr la dimension
psychiatrique ne peut pas être utilisée
comme étant une sorte d'excuse où à la
limite on rend responsable de ce passage
à l'acte l'état du système psychiatrique
en France il y a quelque chose là qui
pose véritablement problème euh cet
homme quel que soit son profil
psychiatrique euh était tout de même un
terroriste dans le passé et était un
terroriste potentiel faut pas oublier
qu'en octobre hein il y a quelques
semaines sa mère avait fait un
signalement qui n'a pas été pris
suffisamment au sérieux auprès des
services responsables ouais c'est c'est
une excuse politique pour certains le
critère psychiatrique y pour rocculter
euh le caractère
oui bien sûr d'ailleurs c'est pas la
première fois que on utilise enfin que
cet argument est utilisé il y a très
souvent cet un argument revient en
disant mais toutère il est fou pour être
terroriste je pense qu'il faut quand
même ne pas avoir une conception très
euh normal de la société mais c'est
surtout que euh faut pas faut pas
occulter le fait que derrière ça il y a
quand même une idéologie une idéologie
de mort une idéologie meurtrière et que
cette idéologie il faut la combattre et
c'est pas en se cachant derrière un
paravant médical et psychiatrique qu'on
arrivera à la combattre il faut vraiment
aller au mal à la racine du mal et la
racine du mal c'est effectivement comme
l'a dit Pascal cette idéologie islamiste
qu'il qu'il l'habite depuis
2015 et qu'il a déjà fait remarquer des
services de police et commencer par
nommer les choses Olivier Pacot le
sénateur apparentel les républicain qui
était là le fait qu'Emmanuel Macron dans
sa première réaction n'avait pas employé
ce mot d'islamiste oui oui je crois
qu'il y a bien au-delà du président de
la
République il y a en ce moment un
véritable problème chez les
commentateurs chez les politiques qui
consiste à ou même dans une partie de
l'appareil judiciaire à ne pas nommer
les choses là aussi attention réaction
de l'opinion parce que l'opinion a
l'impression véritaableblement d'être
roulé dans la farine c'est de manière
claire oui c'est un individu qui avait
des problèmes psychiatrique mais qui
utilise la forme islamiste du terroriste
pour pour s'attaquer à des citoyens
paisible donc il y a bien là oui une
question qu la question de l'islamisme
et puis d'autres facteurs interviennent
autour de cela mais ce sont des fous si
tantz qu'ils soient véritablement fous
qui expriment leur folie meurtrière en
utilisant l'islamisme faut tout de même
avoir bien conscience de cet aspect des
choses la forme d'expression et la forme
d'expression de l'islamisme et on va en
parler hein l'autre question qu'elle
pose c'est la question du suivi des
fichiers puisqu'il était suivi par les
service de renseignement d'abord Alex un
mot avec vous sur les chiffres sur ces
fichiers en France alors d'abord il faut
faire la distinction entre deux fichiers
qui comportte des personnes radicalisées
d'abord les fiches S pour sûreté de
l'État qui regroupe toutes les personnes
qui peuvent porter atteinte à la
sécurité du pays et qui sont surveillés
par les services de renseignement dans
ces fiches s il peut y avoir des
islamistes des militants d'ultraadroite
ou ultra gauche et selon un rapport du
Sénat de fin 2018 il y avait 30000
fichiers en France et puis il y a un
deuxième fichier qu'on appelle le fsprt
pour fichier de traitement des
signalements pour la prévention de la
radicalisation à caractère terroriste il
comprend toutes les personnes signalées
pour radicalisation religieuse et qui
serait susceptible de commettre un
attentat en France ou à l'étranger 20000
personnes sont fichées dans ce fsprt
selon le ministre selon le ministre de
l'Intérieur et 5000 personnes dans ces
20000 font l'objet d'un suivi actif en
fonction de leur dangerosité les
personnes sont surveillées par
différents services cela va de la DGSI
la direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure à la gendarmerie ou la police
on précise qu'une personne peut être à
la fois fich S et faire partie du fsprt
Pascal est-ce que ça pose là aussi la
question du civite C fichers parce que
là il était repéré il était connu des
services de renseignement et pourtant il
a pu commettre cette acte bien sûr ça
pose la question du suivi ça pose la
question bien que ces eff est été
renforcé des effectifs mobilisés
poursivre mais quand on prend les
chiffres qui viennent d'être présentés
20000 30000 même s'il y a des
recoupements entre les deux fichiers
disons quoi à peu près 40000 individus
vous vous rendez compte du nombre de
personnes qu'il faut pour avoir un œil
ou pour suivre pour 5000 d'entre eux de
manière extrêmement attentive ces
individus il faudra encore des effectifs
beaucoup plus importants que ceux dont
l'État français dispose aujourd'hui
donc il y a un vrai véritable problème
de suivi particulièrement pour ces
individus extrêmement dangereux cet
individu était suivi mais était
insuffisamment suivi ouais c'est c'est
une question de moyen du renseignement
Yve oui c'est probablement une question
de moyen ça c'est
incontestable mais on estime qu'il faut
généralement pour un terroriste
peut-être 10 personnes si on veut
vraiment le suivre de façon efficace
mais c'est aussi peut-être une une
question de nomenclature aussi peut-être
est-ce que ces fichiers il faut pas les
reconsidérer dans
leur dans dans dans la
technicité qu'il qu'il requièrent je
sais pas peut-être vous voyez fichiers
ça veut pas dire grand-chose en fait ça
recoupe des gens qui sont très
différents les uns des autres
euh c'est pas pour ça que ce sont des
gens qui peuvent être considérés comme
euh
judiciairement responsable enfin bon il
y il y a beaucoup de peut-être qu'il y a
une chose à revoir là je sais pas parce
que c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois que on
découvre un individu qui fait chess
alors à chaque fois le public je pense
que il faut faire très attention parce
que l'opinion public elle est
extrêmement sensible à ces sujets là et
qu'elle a le sentiment que il y a une
forme d'impuissance derrière et c'est
vrai que le fich S n'est
pas n'est peut-être pas suffisamment
explicité n'est peut-être pas
suffisamment clair dans la tête des gens
parce que qui dit fich aujourd'hui dans
le grand public dit coupable ouais or
c'est pas tout à fait ça le le fich le
la la le le dispositif de la fichesse ne
correspond pas à ça enfin c'est c'est
c'est un autre usage et et puis et puis
c'est des c'est un outil pardon de
travail pour les services de
renseignement mais difficile de
s'attaquer à des personnes tant qu'elles
n'ont pas commis d'acte est-ce que du
coup Pascal ça pose la question de
l'État de droit trop protecteur bien sûr
non mais ça pose la question des
libertés on peut pas mettre par exemple
tous les fichiers dans des cands
administratifs parce que là on va
véritablement
sortir de l'état de droit donc la ligne
de crête n'est pas une ligne facile à
tenir il faudrait certainement comme
vient de le dire distinguer certainement
différents niveaux de dangerosité parce
qu'au fond ces fichier ça cherche à
mesurer une partie de la population
française qui a certains attributs et
parfois beaucoup d'attributs de
dangerosité et de risque de passage à
l'acte et il faut établir j'allais dire
une gradation c'est facile à dire c'est
certainement moins facile à faire hein
une gradation entre les différents
niveaux de dangerosité de ces fichiers
particulièrement pour les fichiè de 2è
type c'est-à-dire ceux qui sont liés au
terrorisme qui baignent j'allais dire
dans une culture dans un un dans des
réseaux qui vont les aider à passer à
l'acte or cet individu était depuis de
nombreux mois et de nombreuses années en
lien avec des terroristes redoutables
donc on voit bien aussi comment à partir
du moment où un individu est en lien
même épisodique ce qui semble être le
cas avec des individus vraiment
dangereux qui ont commu déjà des actes
terroristes là on peut peut-être
envisager des mesures
spécifiques d'encadrement et d'atteinte
oui au liberté d'aller et de venir pour
ce type d'individu notamment l'assassin
de de Samuel pati avec qui il avait été
en contact est-ce que du coup il faut
des réponses législatives Yve pour ces
fichers s particulièrement dangereux lui
avait été condamné en plus pour
préparation d'un acte terroriste la
saillant de Paris est-ce qu'il faut des
mesures législatives pour pouvoir
prendre des mesures avant le passage à
l'acte bah oui il y a une des mesures
c'est la rétention de sûreté euh la
rétention de sûreté qui est dans le
débat depuis euh depuis Rachida datil
hein d'ailleurs je crois que c'est sous
le mandat de Nicolas Sarkozi qui en a
été question la rétention de sortie de
de la rétention euh c'est une
disposition qui va justement heurter
probablement
et bien une c le respect de des droits
de l'homme une fois que vous avez purgé
votre peine bah vous êtes considéré
comme
ayant payé votre dette à la société
comme on dit un peu facilement et
puis quelles sont les motivations qui
font que vous vous pouvez être surveillé
de près
après après l'exécution de cette peine
c'est tout un débat qu'il faut avoir
mais je pense que maintenant il faut
vraiment vraiment le mettre sur la table
parce que encore une fois je pense que
on le constate les terroristes
islamistes
euh quand ils ont commis une fois un
acte et qu' n'ont pas été victimes des
forces de police à ce moment-là parce
qu'ils n'ont pas été bah abattus en gros
euh bah ils sont susceptibles de
recommencer et ces questions elles se
posent également pour le suivi des
radicalisés qui sortent de prison Alex
qu'est-ce qui est prévu à l'heure
actuelle et bien jusqu'à il y a quelques
années des personnes condamnées pour
terrorisme notamment dans la période
entre 2016 et 2020 pouvaient sortir de
prison de manière sèche sans un contrôle
véritablement strict et donc pour
remédier à cette situation et bien des
députés de la majorité présidentielle
emmené par yelbron Pivet et puis des
sénateurs de droite notamment avec la
sénatrice Jacqueline austage brigon ont
porté en 2020 une proposition de loi
prévoyant des mesures de sûreté à
l'encontre de ses ex détenus avec avec
dans ces mesures de sûreté et bien par
exemple certaines obligations
obligations de pointer au commissariat
au maximum trois fois par semaine
obtenir l'autorisation d'un juge pour
changer de résidence avoir interdiction
d'entrer en contact avec certaines
personnes notamment de réseau terroriste
et puis par par exemple aussi
l'obligation de suivre une prise en
charge notamment sanitaire en vue d'une
probable réinsertion des mesures de
sûreté qui peuvent durer 1 an et être
renouvelabl jusqu'à 3 ans alors en 2020
ce texte il avait été censuré par le
Conseil constitutionnel qui estimait que
cela portait une atteinte trop forte au
Liberté les parlementaires l'ont réécrit
un petit peu et duu le corohoré et ont
fait adopter ces mesures de sûreté en
2021 et pour quelques Chi pour avoir
quelques chiffres en 2022 en 2023
environ 200 200 individus condamnés pour
terrorisme sont sortis de prison et les
cas de récidiv sont quand même assez
rares ouais il VO on voir il y a des des
mesures qui ont été prises sont-elles
suffisantes au regard de ce qui s'est
passé alors ce qui s'est passé que le
problème c'est que la réforme dont vous
venez de parler c'est tréformme elle est
pas rétroactive donc l'individu dont il
est question là est pas concerné par
concerné par ce CASL voilà ça c'est
c'est un principe Fran de droit en droit
pénal le vous n'êtes pas il y a pas de
rétroactivité c'est c'est c'est ainsi
donc très bien pour cette pour pour C
pour ces dispositions qui ont ont été
qui ont été prises parce que c'est vrai
qu'on se trouve actuellement dans une
phase où il y a énormément de
terroristes ou de personnes condamnées
pour terrorisme plus ou moins aggravé
qui sont en prison et qui sont en train
de sortir de prison et notamment tous
ceux qui reviennent ce qu'on appelle les
revenants c'est-à-dire ceux qui
reviennent des fronts en Syrie et en
Irak il y en a beaucoup euh donc c'est
pour ça que c ces dispositions ont été
prises est-ce que c'est suffisant disant
on va voir le problème c'est qu'il y a
des trous dans la raquette à chaque fois
on le voit avec l'intéressé là qui
n'était pas éligible à ce dispositif
ouais et il y avait aussi la censure du
Conseil constitutionnel Pascal parce que
y el brun pivé sa proposition de loi
était plus dur il y a eu censure du
Conseil constitutionnel qui a été saisi
par des parlementaires de gauche elbrun
PIV à l'époque elle avait posé la
question du Conseil constitutionnel
est-ce que c'est une question qui se
pose non le Conseil constitutionnel
c'est dans notre dispositif politique
quelque chose de tout à fait important
en particulier pour défendre les
libertés publiques mais c'est au
représentant à l'Assemblée nationale et
au Sénat de prendre en compte le rôle
que joue le Conseil constitutionnel et
de rentrer dans une position et dans une
attitude de compromis avec les attentes
réelles ou supposé du Conseil
constitutionnel c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
s'est passé hein les les parlementaires
ont repris leur travail afin d'arriver
au disposition qui est dispositif qui
aujourd'hui est à l'œuvre donc on voit
bien que il y a nécessité dans un état
de droit il y a de temps en temps
nécessité de restreindre pour certains
types de population porteuse d'attitude
de comportement potentiellement
extrêmement dangereux et qui ont été
déjà dangereux dans le passé de
restreindre ses libertés regardez nous
allons vers les Jeux Olympiques et bien
sur les sites des Jeux Olympiques il va
y avoir une série de mesures qui Laurent
nugès le préfet de police de Paris les a
présenté qui vont restreindre nos
libertés il faut que les citoyens
aujourd'hui devant l'ampleur du défi
terroriste acceptent que certaines de
leur liberté dans des conditions sur
lesquelles par exemple le Conseil
constitutionnel est extrêmement attentif
il faut que les citoyens acceptent aussi
que certaines de leur liberté soient
restreintes mais ça c'est c'est
temporaire est-ce qu'il faut poser la
question plus largement de l'évolution
de la Constitution ce qui s'était posé à
l'époque pour adapter l'État de droit à
la menace terroriste aujourd'hui et à la
menace islamistque certainement il faut
reprendre toujours ces cette tentative
en effet d'encadrer ces population
dangereuse mais là aussi vous savez
c'est provisoire c'est normalement si ma
mémoire est bonne 1 an ça peut aller
jusqu'à 3 ans est-ce qu'il faut pour
certains individus envisager que le
contrôle assez précis soit au-delà de de
de de 3 ans pourquoi pas je veux dire
c'est c'est du débat démocratique qui
est à l'honneur de nos démocraties que
doit doit être issue la réponse à cette
question mais il faut avoir une réponse
s'il y a pas de réponse attention il
faut il faut faire bouger le curseur Yve
entre sécurité des citoyens et liberté
oui vous savez on a un exemple qui est
quand même un exemple assez célèbre
alors là vous allez me dire que c'est
dans une période où justement l'État
israélien était pris en défaut mais si
vous vous prenez l'État d'Israël l'État
d'Israël n'arrête pas depuis 1948 depuis
sa création de mettre à jour sa de
mettre à jour sa sa sa législation pour
justement essayer de contrer la menace
terroriste qui d'ailleurs a été très
réduite par rapport à ce qu'elle avait
été il y a quelques années bon il s'est
passé
depuis le le 7 le 7 octobre mais euh
faut pas hésiter je crois que le
discours qui consiste à dire mais c'est
laè loi et tout c'est ridicule ce
discours est ridicule parce que on voit
bien que les terroristes justement font
évoluer aussi leur mode d'action leur
mode opératoire il faut toujours que la
société se protège le le le le plus
possible en ayant un et ben en est en
ayant des dispositions qui soient des
dispositions qui qui qui préviennent ce
type d'acte et d'ailleurs dans notre
pays la dernière grande évolution
législative pour lutter contre le
terrorisme euh c'était la loi silt
c'était en 2017 c'était au début du
premier quinquenat d'Emmanuel Macron et
euh à l'époque le président de la
République avait voulu introduire les
mesures de l'état d'urgence pris
notamment sous François Hollande après
les attentats de 2015 et 2016 il avait
voulu introduire une partie de ces
mesures dans l'État de droit euh pour
pouvoir lutter plus efficacement euh
contre les terroristes un mot Yve sur ce
que vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure
sur la question de la déradicalisation
euh c'est aussi la question que ça pose
euh est-ce qu'il est possible de
déradicaliser euh des individus alors on
est bien placé ici au Sénat puce qu'il y
a un rapport qui a été fait il y a
quelques années par des sénater des
sénatrices oui de de de de de sénatrices
dont une qui s'appelle Esther ben Bassa
qui peut pas être suspectter je dirais
d'être vraiment très autoritaire et de
d'aller à l'encontre des libertés
publicque et bien au terme de ce rapport
il est dit que la déradicalisation est
un processus qui est très incertain et
que c'est très difficile de Dér
déradicaliser quelqu'un qui a été
idéologisé au nom de l'islamisme tout ça
sur la foi de d'études qui ont été
conduites à l'étranger enfin c'est très
très très très très difficile Pascal si
vous voulez les formes mêmes Gil kepppel
l'a bien montré du djihadisme ont évolué
hein c'était un
djihadisme au départ qui était un
djihadisme organisé par le sorte de chef
d'orchestre clandestin maintenant c'est
un un djihadisme beaucoup plus diffus un
djihadisme presque ordinaire du
quotidien euh avec des individus qui
sont beaucoup plus difficiles
certainement à suivre et sur lesquels il
est be il est très difficile de de
prévoir leur passage à l'acte si vous
voulez à l'évolution de cette de ces
formes du djihadisme doit répondre une
évolution des formes de lutte contre le
terrorisme euh islamiste euh et je suis
tout je partage tout à fait ce sentiment
parce que on est là sans arrêt ce que
vient de dire on est là sans arrêt à
dire ah c'est la Xe l' Xè règlement loi
et cetera bah bien sûr la société change
donc il est assez normal que les
dispositifs de lutte changent il il y a
des moyens qui ont été mis pour le coup
notamment dans les le renseignement dans
les prisons dans le renseignement
pénitentiaire puisqu'il y a eu ces
fameux quartiers d'évaluation et de
prévention de la
radicalisation qui ont été mis en place
justement pour lutter contre entre cette
radicalisation en prison et pour essayer
de déradicaliser les gens qui sont
radicalisés ça montre ses limites pour
vous non mais c'est sûr que bon si vous
voulez il y a la réflexion elle elle
doit continuer mais c'est sûr que la
prison a toujours été considérée comme
un lieu de radicalisation c'est comme
très souvent par le passé on vous disait
que la prison c'était l'école du crime
finalement c'est là où malheureusement
c'est ça mais parce que on a un système
pénitentiaire qui est alors faut pas
généraliser non plus mais il faut s'
sans doute le moderniser il faut faire
en sorte que justement il y ait des
contacts entre les individus qui soient
plus difficiles il faut pas mélanger les
populations enfin il y a tout il y a
toute il y a plein de techniques si vous
voulez qu'on peut pas exposer ici mais
qui doivent être mis en œuvre
euh c'est sûr qu'il faut qu'on là-dessus
on travaille énormément parce que on le
sait très bien que il y a aujourd'hui
dans le milieu pénitentiaire énormément
de d'individus qui sont radicalisés et
qui sont susceptibles de radicaliser
d'autres on l'a vu par le passé on a
plein d'exemples de gens qui se sont
radicalisés en prison Pascal tout à
l'heure vous vous nous parliez du regard
que que porte l'opinion publique sur ce
qui s'est passé et et vous nous avez dit
ça peut avoir des conséquences graves
lesquels là on s'aperçoit en effet que
le niveau d'inquiétude je dirais pas
tant son maximum ça peut encore aller
plus haut mais c'est de l'ordre de près
de 90 % des Français qui se déclarent
être très préoccupés euh par la
situation actuelle et qu'on l'impression
que peu à peu la société française
devient une société de tous les dangers
qu'on court un risque en sortant de chez
soi à 9h du soir ce qui était le cas en
effet de de de de ces touristes pour
aller voir la Tour Effel vous voyez donc
il y a une inquiétude et cette
inquiétude quand elle devient une
inquiétude de masse est très mauvaise
conseillère parce que si cette opinion
publique a l'impression que la puissance
publique est est impuissante ou qu'elle
n'est pas tout à fait à la hauteur et
bien peu à peu cette opinion peut se
tourner vers des solutions beaucoup plus
radicales au plan politique qui seraiit
des des des solutions autoritaires et
personne n'a quelque chose à gagner à ce
type d'évolution éventuelle mais
concrètement ça profiterait à qui dans
les urnes oh pour l'instant ça profite
de manière évidente au rassemblement
national on a entendu d'ailleurs Jean b
ouiou b il y a pas de il y a pas de
problème on est dans une dans une
période effectivement où le
rassemblement national
euh a un discours qui correspond aux
inquiétudes de la de la population donc
ça ça lui correspond il y a une espèce
de radicalisation des esprits il faut le
dire et bon ben voilà ça va être très
difficile
de de sortir de cette logique un dernier
mot parce que ça c'est dans les urnes
mais après ce qui s'est passé à crpool
on a entendu Olivier verrand parler d'un
risque de basculement de la
société anin parlerit d'un d'un risque
de scénario de guerre civile est-ce que
ça c'est réaliste pour vous Pascal bon
le scénario de guerre civile il faut
être extrêmement prudent en effet dans
le manimement de de de ce thème de la
guerre civile même si jusqu'à maintenant
certains hommes de lettes je pense en
particulier à Michel Welbeck vous savez
il faut toujours lire les les les
auteurs de de romans parfois ils ont
voilà ils anticipent hein espérons que c
anti iticipation n'est pas tout à fait
exacte et ne laisse pas pressentir ce
qui pourrait advenir en France mais ce
qui est très dangereux à plus court
terme c'est que lorsque les citoyens ont
l'impression en effet que la puissance
publique n'est pas suffisamment efficace
il peut y avoir la tentation de se faire
justice soi-même hein et vous avez dans
cette fameuse ultra droite dont on nous
a rebattu les les oreilles pendant
pendant environ une semaine et bien il y
a la dimension la volonté
hein de se faire justice soi-même
c'était en effet ces quelques
80 jeune de l'ultradroite qui se portait
vers le quartier à crépool après
l'assassinat de crpool dont les les les
les jeunes assassins étaient originaires
ça c'est une évolution extrêmement
préoccupante de la société française on
va continuer à parler de ce sujet ça
fait la Une du Figaro et la une de la
presse régionale on
regarde
[Musique]
et Alex C attenta fait donc la une de la
presse régionale et oui après cette
attaque au couteau le profil du tueur
pose question tout comme son suivi c'est
à la une du Midi Libre de ouest- France
et de Sud-Ouest on le rappelle ce
franco-iranien de 26 ans était ficher s
avait fait 4 ans de prison pour un
projet d'attaque terroriste et depuis sa
sortie il faisait l'objet de mesurees de
contrôle de surveillance également d'un
suivi médical car il avait des troubles
psychiatriques d'ailleurs dans le jour
al sud-ouest l'imam de ceom près de
Bordeaux qui intervient dans un centre
de déradicalisation explique que 77 %
des personnes radicalisées qui les a
suivi présenta une fragilité
psychologique et 16 % relevai de la
psychiatrie le journal press océan
revient sur une autre actualité c'est la
mort d'un supporter de foot Nanta ce
weekend oui un supporter du FC Nantes
qui est mort samedi lors d'une
altercation en en marge du match entre
Nantes et Nice le drame est survenu
alors que des supporters nantais
attaquaient des supporters niceois ser
rendant au stade en VTC et hier un
chauffeur de VTC s'est rendu à la police
il a été placé en garde à vue on
rappelle que le supporter Nanta a
vraisemblablement été tué avec une arme
blanche à la Une de La Provence le pire
a été évité dans l'incendie d'un
immeuble à Marseille ce weekend oui dans
la nuit de samedi à dimanche un immeuble
du 4e arrondissement de la cité fausenne
a pris feu après une explosion sans
doute liée à une fuite de gaz l'incident
a fait SEP blessés une trentaine de
personnes ont été relogées un bilan sans
grande gravité qui rappelle euh
forcément le terrible effondrement de la
rue Tivoli au printemps dernier qui
avait fait h morts allez on finit par un
peu de légèreté une bonne nouvelle c'est
la Saint-Nicolas cette semaine c'est à
la une du républicain Laurin et oui un
peu de joie un peu de fête puisque
c'était un weekend de fête dans toute la
Lorine et notamment à mes Saint-Nicolas
a défilé dans les rues de la ville
suivie par de nombreux enfants on le
rappelle la Saint-Nicolas c'est une fête
du calendrier chrétien mais
Saint-Nicolas c'est aussi le patron le
saint patron de la Lorine donc c'est une
fête très importante dans la région et
puis pour les enfants turbulents le pre
Fouettard a également fait son
apparition merci Alex ilon regarde la
Une du Figaro après l'attentat question
sur un islamiste en liberté bah oui
c'est question que bah il y a de toute
manière après chaque attentat il y a
beaucoup de questions qui se posent donc
le principal c'est de trouver les
réponses c'estàd les réponses ce matin
dans Le Figaro merci merci beaucoup if
TR merci beaucoup Pascal Perino d'avoir
été avec nous merci Alex on se retrouve
demain prochain rendez-vous sur notre
antenne c'est à 18h vous avez
rendez-vous avec Thomas H pour le sens
public et nous on se retrouve donc
demain on vous souhaite un TR très bonne
journée